hello and welcome everybody to you'd ask
these robotics QA I'm Mike Salem and I'm
here with CEO and co-founder of traffic
Louis Anderson Louis how are you doing
well today thank you great nice to have
you in studio yeah I'm really excited to
be here it's always fun to talk to
a bunch of people excited about robotics
definitely so I wanted to talk to you a
little bit about traffic so what exactly
is traffic doing we are developing a
strawberry harvest machine so basically
agriculture is facing this really
serious labor shortage where they can't
find out people to pick the strawberries
so they can grow the strawberries and
whatever quantity they want they can't
find a people to pick them so a lot of
growers are having to leave some
percentage 10 20 30 percent of their
field unharvested in a peak season
especially the end of this season and
this labor shortage pose to get a lot
worse it's supposed to and the flavor
supposed to get a lot more expensive so
this is a threat that's it's threatening
to drive them out of business
so we solved this problem by developing
a machine that can harvest raw berries
we use robot arms 3d cameras powerful
computers along with AI computer vision
custom gripper to develop machine that
you bolt the back of a tractor you drive
it up and down the field and it picks
strawberries interesting so Before we
jump really into some of the more
specifics of your actual company what's
your background where did you come from
prior to doing robotics for let's say
your company it's a good question so I
did just before this I was working at
Microsoft is there for three years
working on PowerPoint on the office
build system doing non robotics and on
computer videos diet before that I did a
computer science degree at UCSD
okay let's UC San Diego and I worked on
an autonomous airplane team there so
this is for a student competition where
we built in fluent airplane that flew
itself did have an aerial surveillance
competition did a lot of computer vision
for that and some classes and it was
kind of my real my first real exposure
to taking these really cool software
ideas and getting them out into the real
world interacting with real world we can
have a bigger impact interesting
interesting
so you came from more of a software
background kind of getting into robotics
versus more of a hardware background
correct I was totally software it seems
like most people I end up talking to
usually come from a mechanical
engineering background first or
electrical engineering and then they
kind of move in what was that experience
like for you
kind of coming from the softwar world
and kind of slowly learning like the
more mechanical electrical side of
things it was super hard you know people
say hardware is hard it's totally true
so I think the first thing I did was I
got a 3d camera so I've been talking to
customers to figure out whether this was
something people wanted I think that's
always the first step is make sure
there's a need for this wait so now I
bought a 3d camera is carrying around
the strawberry fields trying to do this
like write software that would identify
ripe strawberries I was like okay I got
it working I was like this is great it's
the hardest part now I need to go pick
them and so I like I started going
online looking for robot arms and I
bought one I had this robot arm like my
hand and 3d cameras like okay how do I
put these together it's veggie build a
frame like all this other stuff and I
was I was really bad at it and honestly
my solution was to bring my co-founder
on board because he's a hardware guy
great guy by the way yeah
so so so then joined pretty soon after I
started doing this and since then he's
done all the hard work and that was
really a lot better he's has a
mechanical engineering background shear
so it's nice so this is an example of an
interdisciplinary type of field right so
somebody who's who's purely a software
based person or more more of a software
bent I shouldn't say purely software
based but more of a software bent tend
to require other skills like mechanical
skills or electrical skills or even in
some cases designers right to kind of
come in and bring all of these things
together so it's really nice to kind of
see how it's a big melting pot for
everybody to kind of get involved yeah
you know I think that if you're doing
like a like a hobby level project it's
fun to do all of it because you can
learn a bunch and that's exciting and
it's challenging I think if you want to
commercialize it really it's good to get
a bunch of people together with
different skill sets at least like two
or three people someone's good at
software someone's got a hardware
because you can just accomplish so much
more that way and really everyone ends
up doing a little bit of everything
because you're working so closely
together so what's what's typically your
favorite application as far as what
you're working on for the robot yourself
so I know you it sounds like you've
actually went and sourced some
commercial off-the-shelf parts like a
robotic arm but I know a lot of your
hardware stat are sorry excuse me your
software stack it's probably built
in-house you guys
probably doing a lot of work to kind of
make sure everything's seen you know
stitches together seamlessly your
favorite part of kind of the software
realm what do you what do you typically
like to do favorite part of the software
realm you know I think my most exciting
the most exciting part is getting things
to work I'm actually I care a little bit
less about how stuff gets done but when
I see all the pieces work together
that's really awesome so I try really
really hard to use off-the-shelf things
so if a hardware that's going you know
to a store to buy something or to a
hardware provider to buy something for
software that's using open-source
libraries using existing data sets
basically using as much stuff as you can
that other people build obviously stuff
that's really available make sure you
respect the licenses but trying to build
as little as possible yourself I think
that when you when you have good
engineers they get excited about
building things and you have to be
careful to make sure you don't build too
much and don't like reinvent things
already exist in terms of other things
we've actually had to build so we use
neural networks so we get we take a
bunch of images of the strawberry field
okay on a very rapid cadence and we have
to identify ripe strawberries in them so
a ripe strawberry is entirely red so
strawberry does partially red partially
Green is not ripe so I was intelliwhite
is not ripe so using neural network to
find those ripe strawberries and I think
training the neural network was really
fun in kind of a weird way because it
seemed like this this hard problem to
like write something that would do this
but then I got the data set together in
the right way I use people mechanical
turk so first of all I went I captured
all the data myself and then I used
people in Mechanical Turk to label the
data set how can you explain with
Mechanical Turk is for some of those
people who aren't really familiar with
it it's actually a resource it's really
cool so it's this service Amazon run so
Amazon Mechanical Turk where basically
there's a bunch of people behind this
and you submit tasks that are good for
humans to do and the humans will do
these tasks and you get the results and
so you can and they have a large group
of people so you can take a task
and run it like a million times sure and
get the result in 24 hours and you don't
have to manage the people you just set
up on this web interface and they handle
the management they charge you for the
time so that's a great tool to have if
you're kind of a small agile company
that's trying to get going and you need
a lot of resources kind of quickly I'm
kind of a mundane level task yeah I'm
kind of go to this Mechanical Turk and
say help me out really quick they get
paid you get the results that you need
and you can kind of move forward yeah
you can get this massive scale for a
short period of time without having to
worry about hiring all these people very
cool useful so what else was in your
tool chain I know you talked about a
little bit of doing
you know neural networks on the zooming
convolutional neural nets because you're
talking about images you don't Amazon to
kind of help classify what kind of tools
what kind of tool chain what kind of
programming languages are you typically
using what kind of software tools are
you using to accommodate those languages
yeah so in terms of our stack so we do
almost everything on Linux a couple of
libraries views on Linux only so that is
why we use Linux so we used Python and
C++ as the two languages initially I try
to do a lot of stuff in Python slowly
reporting more but to C++ for
performance reasons and so it can all be
kind of in one language we use OpenCV
quite heavily we use point cloud library
a fair amount we use Ross for
communicating between our Python and C++
nodes let's see on the neural network
side we're using cafe for that
interesting okay let's see was there a
reason for cafe over something like
let's say you know Kara's or you
tensorflow or Theano or yeah there's
there's a specific neural network that
we wanted to use and someone had built
it on top of cafe okay great so that's
it that's going back to your original
point of trying not to reinvent the
wheel right absolutely that the tools
that are available for you at the
beginning and try to utilize those tool
to the maximum potential and then that
way you can get going on the problem
that you actually want to solve instead
of trying to build a solution to solve
the problem from the very beginning yeah
like you have to look at what you're
what what part of your solution is
unique to you
and try to focus all your time on
solving that and making that really cool
and spend less time on you know redoing
things other people done so the really
cool thing about using that open source
code was once once I got the data
labeled and like all together and a fold
in the right format I was able to get
the null Network to do what I wanted in
like three days very cool yeah it was
like what I thought was a reasonably
hard computer-vision challenge and just
solved just like that it was pretty fast
it was reliable so let me ask you a
question about some of the data that you
captured so obviously you're taking it
sounds like you're doing you know RGB D
type of images right yeah how many
images do you have of strawberries way
too many um so I think our give a rough
count you know thousands tens of
thousands I think when we train the
neural network we had thousands of
berries Wow so you have to have berries
that are both ripe and unripe right
because you have to be able to identify
in a network that this is a good berry
versus this is a bad berry yes what we
actually did is we took images of
sections of the field I'm pretty close
up so maybe like four or five feet of a
row and we had people Mechanical Turk
draw a box around the ripe strawberries
and we just did nothing with the unripe
ones and it no one I've just learned to
ignore those perfect that's a great
approach for actually solving that
problem yeah so let's talk a little
about your robot grasper a little so I
know you said you bought this thing is
commercial off-the-shelf and I know some
people actually in our slack community
had some concerns about whoa how do you
know if you're applying the right amount
of force and pressure to kind of pull
these things off how do you not crush
these berries as you're bringing them in
what kind of challenges did you kind of
see when you first started working with
your robotic arm that's a good question
so the kind of two separate components
there there's the the gripper itself
that actually touches the berries and is
mounted kind of on like a little stick
and then there's the robot arm that
actually moves it into the right
position for the robot arm itself the
very first one we got was like $200 it
was a hobbyist sixaxis arm and then once
who is our first round of funding we
want we bought an arm on eBay a four
axis scar arm I think it's that in a 3m
factory for like ten years
okay so the during the delicacy is a
little challenging because the robots
we're using are not collaborative robots
so a collaborative robot if you apply
enough force to it it'll stop so it's
kind of safe to be around okay ours will
just you tell to go to position it will
go there regardless of what's in the way
okay so you really have to be careful so
we have to be home on the vision side to
tell it where it's okay to go and where
it's not on the vision the path planning
so that the path we give it is is safe
to go to and then on the gripper itself
in terms of not smashing it the initial
idea that we had was to use pressure
sensors for that so you just you close
until you have a certain mount of force
then you stop right but this didn't work
as well as we thought they would so
actually the jury's still out on whether
we use those or not some of the other
ways is just designing hardware that
will kind of automatically conform to
the shape of an object in a way that
kind of applies even pressure doesn't
squeeze too hard something like almost
like a foam okay yeah insulator to kind
of help cusp it basically right and then
apply enough force nothing gets damaged
no interesting very cool with regards to
moving your arm you said that there's
really no there's no real like safety
stop right so if I were to move the arm
if I were to give it some sort of motion
path and you know plan out the path and
it executes this path and let's say a
person's the way a person's going to you
know potentially depending on how strong
the arm is knock them down or get them
injured yeah often times with the
strawberry bush there might be a
strawberry that's kind of a little bit
further back then you know right at the
front where it's a ripe strawberry how
would your arm go about trying to find
one of those strawberries is that a
challenge is that something that you
kind of say well we'll just leave this
one on the vine for now and kind of
revisit this or it is a challenge so
what we do there is the first fall the
strawberry plants themselves are they're
weirdly like flexible and durable so you
can kind of run an arm through them
pretty fast like pretty low off the
ground and like it'll they'll hit a
bunch of
using stems and stuff and won't damage
the plant at all so kind of if you're
hitting some leaves on the way to the
berry that's okay the one thing we have
to keep in mind is that if you have like
a plant here and a berry here and you
approach from this side if you like or
hitting the plant that'll move to berry
and then you end up trying to grab where
the berry was rather than where it is
it's a little mess so we kind of try to
be clever about the the path we follow
to get there
engage but our solution is a lot simpler
than we initially thought it would have
to be well that's great I think I think
one of the surprising things about
robotics is like at the beginning I sat
down I tried to think of all the hard
problems like what's going to be hard
and what's going to be easy right
and then now looking back the list was
totally wrong like a lot of things we
thought would be really hard we solved
quickly and then things that we had
never thought of would be issues end up
being hard so do you talk about some of
those issues that you thought were hard
that you didn't really think there were
going to be yeah I think I don't find
the ripe strawberries was one of them
kind of that open source neural network
that we use just magic magically solve
that problem what else was was easy the
second thing was we we our goal is to
pick a strawberry per second per robot
arm so we're going to build a machine
you bolt the back foot tractor has a
bunch of arms on it the four to eight
robot arms each arm as a gripper and we
want each of those arms to be picking a
berry per second all going in parallels
there picking pretty fast and basically
the only hardware out there that would
work was robot arms intended for factory
use so these are big heavy things you
bolt to the floor right there in a
relatively clean environment there's no
vibration there's not much water and so
we knew okay we that's the arm we want
has amazing specs they last for like
30,000 hours of continuous use we want
to get it out in the field where it's
like lots of vibration or mounting to
much smaller object and there's
potential dust and dirt and water and so
you know is that gonna be a problem
we're afraid that like they just
wouldn't work out there and so far that
part was relatively easy
we started to make sure we have we buy
arms that have the right environmental
rating against dust and water and they
sort of just work so what are some of
the harder problems that you face that
you thought would be easy building a
frame really those yeah so what why is
that let's we have all these components
and we need to put them in the right
place and they're they're kind of heavy
and so you need a frame that can support
their weight so the frame ends up being
kind of heavy in the initial version of
the frame we didn't want to involve the
tractor because we didn't want to take
up too much of our customers time when
we're doing our initial task so it just
has like a big frame that has four
wheels on it and it's like 10 feet long
like 6 or 7 feet wide and it weighs like
500 pounds and so then we push it by
hand through the row what we figured out
is it takes basically all three of us if
it's like at all muddy it takes all
three of us to move this so you set
there like like like pushing on it
really hard just trying to get it to
move in the field so you're skipping
your gym days and days that you're out
doing fees actually yeah don't need to
exercise so so the frame was actually
one of the things that you thought would
actually be really easy that turned out
to be a lot more complicated because you
had weight restrictions and trying to
figure out maneuverability once you're
out in the field yet weight and
durability and also these arms that
we're doing I really we're buying a
really fast we want to be able to fast
and very per second so it's like it's
like something like this pace but moving
over or like possibly a meter so so
moving over 3/4 of a meter and going
down to grab something then moving back
all in a second these are relatively
heavy and so when they when they do that
they accelerate really quickly and so a
heavy thing celebrating quickly puts a
lot of force in the frame so you also
need a frame that can withstand that
force and provide a relatively stable
mount without falling over or falling
apart or anything like that
definitely definitely I can see the
challenges there so you talked about
having like a three person team right so
is having a small team do you feel it's
advantageous at this stage or do you
feel like you know having a couple other
members would make the load a little bit
easier what's it like being kind of
like I would say startup stage right so
what's it kind of like being the startup
right now in Silicon Valley in robotics
super exciting I think we're kind of
small team is really fun because you can
you're all in the same place you can
talk really easily bounce ideas off each
other and try crazy things I think our
team is definitely the right size right
now we have the necessary hardware and
software skill set and in terms of team
size is sort of a trade-off between how
quickly you can get stuff done and how
much money you need to raise sure so in
our case we all want salaries because we
have to pay rent might eat food
occasionally living in Bay Area is
deathly expensive right high cost of
living here absolutely
so and if we if we hire more people and
that shortens our runway we have less
people then we have much longer runway
or we can raise less money which means
less dilution typically but then you
lost people get less stuff done I think
three people feels like the really
really good fries you're at right now
yeah really good lean yeah so it easy to
tackle all problems yeah so we brought
Brian on board is a third person about
two or three months ago he and I have
been he and then and I worked together
on the airplane team so we all work
together before so you already have
chemistry already have a dynamic you
know how to work with each other yeah I
think that's super important if you can
like this isn't always possible but if
you can get people you've worked with
before that really reduces the risk in
terms of whether you're going to have
personality or communication conflicts
on the team so he joined two months so
it says it was like just me for a couple
months few months and then then joined
has been an eye for like six months and
then he joined and we really saw our
each time like when then drawing to them
when Brian joined we saw big jumps in
productivity like I swear when we went
from two to three people I think our
productivity like doubled or tripled
that's a good return on investment right
yeah you expect okay if you're
increasing your workforce by 50% you
probably get 50% more done assuming you
scale well but we actually saw much a
much like better output than that
so I think that's possible people work
together well interesting so small teams
are always kind of good to start out
with and if you need to add people it's
easier to add knowing that your
workloads kind of set up for you in the
future exactly or less yeah if you scale
to like you know six or seven people
well to the early is to raise a lot of
money or you only have like you know six
months of runway show which means you
don't have enough time to build the
technology so what's it like trying to
raise money for you know a robotic
startup it's a good question um how did
you go about it for your first round if
I can ask that question you can yeah so
we raised $400,000 from k9 ventures
which is a micro VC in this area and
that was back in October so the way I
went about that process is I tried to
build a list of all the investors that I
thought would be good candidates for
investing in us I tried to find people
that had done robotics or some kind of
hardware startups before because because
really hard where you get getting
investments a hardware startup is a bit
harder than as a software one in our
case we try to we think all over tones
of software's and we're you know still
still a good fit there but a lot of
investors won't really touch hardware so
we tried I tried to come up with a list
of start of investors that had invested
in hardware startups were set on their
website that they want to do that and
then I like I paid for the premium
LinkedIn thing for like a month and I
went through all these people and I
tried to figure out who what connections
we had in common so I figure out which
of this list of investors we I had
second-degree connections with okay and
then was like probably the most
emotionally challenging stop the whole
process I went to each of these to like
the shared connection all times these
were people maybe that it worked just
recently but some of them I like I
hadn't worked with a long time right
people from college or or previous jobs
and I just sent an email and as hey like
I see that you're connected this person
would you be comfortable doing a quick
email intro sure and the really cool
part of that process is is I got a
really good response from that I think
people are super helpful I think as long
as you're respectful Hawaii right
professional professional yeah people
are really willing to help and so a lot
of people made that intro and getting a
warm intro from investors is really
important I think it's probably
necessary the vast majority of cases so
then get this email intro and I'd send a
short blurb about the company and then
some percentage of the investors were
willing to meet and so we'd meet and
kind of go from there so what was it
like as far as what would you tell
investors I mean did you have a product
at that point you have proof of concept
did you have just kind of an idea that
was still in your head like I want to
build a strawberry picking robot and the
investors were like well do you have a
proof of concept or you know you have
some simulation what was it what was
your approach your method kind of going
so it's a good question most of things
that I've heard say that it's really
hard to raise investment if you don't
have some kind of prototype to show I
think some people can do it like if
people done a successful startup before
then they can raise a first round with
basically just a you know pitch deck but
in our case we we built a prototype was
a really early prototype we had a video
of it picking a couple strawberries in a
real field so it kind of showed the
whole system working together so we had
that proof that we could even if it
wasn't like quite with the final product
we proved that we could do something
like it's not a pipe dream you actually
have something that you can show that
you can iterate them yeah so with k-9
the first thing we had was at their
office and for the second meeting they
came to our garage and we could show him
a robot in person that was fun the other
half of the the pitch that we made we
had statements of support from for
strawberry growers on a pepper grower so
these are letters that the growers wrote
basically non-binding things saying hey
we talked to Luis we think this is a
great idea we are super interested in
paying for this as soon as it becomes
available
and we showed these to all the investors
and it demonstrated that there was an
for this so ideally you get like some
kind of you really want proof of some
kind of customer attraction ideally a
prototype that's baited that's like out
in the field generating revenue but in
our case that was an option so we had
this these letters and that really went
a long way towards proving that we
talked to these people that they're
receptive that they really wanted this
and that there was a big enough market
for it so when you talk to these these
farmers or these customers if you will
strawberry blends in the pepper one how
would they end up utilizing your product
in the end what they end up purchasing
your product or would they end up
renting your product what's the what's
kind of the strategy going forward for
once this is actually deployed yeah so
our strategy is hard work or harvest as
a service okay
so we build this machine put it out in
their fields and they pay either per
month of usage or per pound of
strawberries that it picks okay so
currently they pay their human workforce
on a piece rate basis they pay a certain
amount for every pound of strawberries
so we would just charge the same way and
this is really awesome because first of
all is a very low barrier to entry when
they first start using it you try to
convince someone to fork over a million
dollars before having seen anything at
all like they're not going to do that I
mean or maybe it's going to just take a
really long time if you say okay you
don't have to pay anything put it in the
field after two weeks so it's working
you pay us otherwise you don't the super
low risk for the for the customers and
they feel comfortable with that it also
ensures that long term you have a
recurring revenue stream mate so that
you're not constantly to make new sales
you are making new sales but you're
renting out your product again for reuse
so as an easing or in demand basis yeah
and then at the end of the day it really
makes mixes that everyone's incentives
are aligned our incentives are to make
sure that our product is working just as
well or better you know after three
years in the field as it was the first
day we deployed it if you sell something
for an upfront payment and like charge
more for maintenance just potentially
weird incentives in this case it's it
actually keeps your cost down a lot too
right because you don't have to go
through this big manufacturing process
of you know maybe sending out you know
5,000 or 10,000 robotic arms you might
be able to cut that down to let's say a
thousand or 2,000 robotic arms now you
to reiterate
make improvements right yeah and the
fast iteration is also real important
things so if we own the machines we can
swap hardware components whenever we
want midseason we can push software
updates over-the-air every night so we
can keep iterating on these really
quickly if you do upfront sales you get
to iterate every time you sell a new
unit but if you're if you're owning
these and doing as a service you can
iterate every day if you want sure a lot
better so you talked briefly about this
pepper and I'm kind of fixated in my
mind now because your strawberry picker
yeah right that's your goal right now
yeah any goals to move into peppers or
so changing to different fruits or
vegetables or yeah so the the business
problems that strawberry growers are
having around their labor in terms of
the labor availability primarily growers
and other crops are facing the same
problems so something like half of
fruits and vegetables are not automated
in terms of the harvest and that the
harvest is super expensive so it
accounts for something like 30% of the
total cost of producing the fruit the
fruit or vegetable so the total cost of
land and the fertilizer in the water and
and all that of that a third of it is
just the the manual labor to pick the
crop so that and this problem is faced
by about half of fruits and vegetables
and so a long-term plan is to to do
strawberries first and then slowly
expanded to other crops and so I wanted
to show that there were there was indeed
some demand from at least one grower
share outside and there was a pepper
grower and nearby that got introduced to
so it's pretty easy interesting so it
sounds like you can use virtually the
same hardware as well right you software
might take a slight modification in your
neural net because you'd have to train
for peppers let's say instead of
strawberries yeah it's essentially more
or less the same the same idea that's a
good question um I think so yeah you
want to reuse as much as possible I
think venom Brian might disagree with me
on that they might say there's more
hardware changes needed than that
between crops you try not to upset your
coworkers yeah your co-founder gonna
promise so they're going to do all kinds
of things so if I'm an aspiring robot
assist if I'm somebody who's kind of
interested in getting into the field
what's my path to entry in your
perspective
that's a good question what are the
necessary steps that I can start taking
now to kind of say I have this idea I
had this dream my head I want to build
this robot and I want to take it all the
way to market I want to pitch it to
somebody and I want to I want to start
my company that's a good question I
would say you probably need to make sure
you have the technical skills necessary
obviously make sure you can code if I'm
the software side make sure you can do
any of the machine learning of the
computer vision stuff that you need same
on the hardware side if you want to do
it as a if you want to build a
commercial product that means to me
probably doing as a startup like there's
other ways to do it but that's probably
the most common way and I think the path
there is sort of the same as other
startups so the most important thing is
to make sure there's there's a need for
it make sure that there's customer
interest and to prove that customer
interest in some way statements of
support from customers are great or you
know interviews with people or some kind
of evidence that that not only is there
a problem but that people will accept
your solution you do your market
research as well exactly yeah because it
might be a great robot it might be a
great final product but if there's no
demand for it it's going to be very hard
to get funding typically yeah you need
to make sure there's an atom and you
also need to make sure the business
model works so you figure out when you
deploy this what's your return on
investment going to be how long does it
take to pay back your capital investment
so do that and then come on the
technical side building a prototype is
useful try to build the the worst
prototype yet imagine the simplest
hackie is may just something that proves
it like the idea is kind of plausible
and then get it out there and maybe
raise around the funding find people
work with you so the first two to four
months I did this I was by myself I
don't recommend that I think being a
solo founder really sucks sure it's
really lonely actually it's a lot more
fun to be working with someone yeah I
definitely could see that it's nice to
have other ideas coming in you know
being able to collaborate bring to
thanks to the table exactly get much
more varied ideas and you know it's not
always practical for everyone to find a
co-founder sure like sometimes you want
to make sure you work to the person
before and sometimes you know you got
all your friends and none of them are
interested in doing a start-up and so
you look ok I'll do it by myself
that's fine right so the agriculture
space in agricultural robotics and in
general right they're starting to be a
lot of buzz right and there's some other
there's other companies that are in this
realm are you looking to expand into
first of all let me ask this question I
guess how do you differentiate yourself
from some of you some of your
competitors I know there's some
competitors there's a there's a company
in Spain that does a strawberry picking
robot as well how do you differentiate
yourself in the market from somebody
like let's say someone doing a lettuce
bot or weeding bot or you know picking
potatoes or something like that that's a
good question
so there's two answers to that first of
all this bunch of companies doing
agriculture robotics that are not
strawberry harvest those companies are
definitely not at all our competitors so
there's such an enormous number of
opportunities in agriculture that is
room for a ton of companies to go after
this so I see a lot of these companies
as collaborators you know there's
there's lettuce thinning there's a
harvesting company there's there's
others and we really see them as
potential collaborators and allies and
not at all as competitors terms a couple
companies going after strawberry harvest
there are more competitors to us and so
one of the big differentiating factors
for us first of all is that we want to
make it so that you can deploy this
machine in a field as is with no growing
change necessary so same breed of plant
same shape and size of beds same density
so you can throw this machine out there
in the middle of the season with you
know no prep if you want and so the
Spanish company egg robot they were
quite a grow in a different
configuration that means you have much
lower plant density of having lower
yield and so becomes a lot more
expensive to grow overall in terms of
our solution we'll be able to deploy it
in traditional fields
which means you get all the economic
benefits of this really efficient
growing system that they have and you
can solve harvest so yeah I noticed that
some other companies they have more of a
the robots still require a lot more
human intervention it sounds like then
what you're offering right yours is more
of a only pick the ripe strawberry and
put it down versus more of a sweeping
rate way of picking up a bunch of
strawberries and still having a human
system before packaging yeah and so it's
important to clarify the we do see the
still as labor augmentation our goal is
not to replace all the labor to augment
it so we probably especially for the
first little while will miss on
percentage of the fruit so they'll send
humans to afterwards to kind of clean up
the stuff we missed so our goal is to
make sure that the growers can take
their workforce which is naturally
shrinking and supply and grow more
strawberries so increase their yield
with decreasing labor so we think that
if we deploy that well we just really
naturally solve this problem everyone
who wants a job will still have one but
the same time the the growers businesses
will do well in G ok so let me go ahead
and take some questions from our slack
community cool so we have lots of
questions actually this week for you
which is great all right so exciting let
me go ahead and pull up a few of them so
here's one from YouTube which neural
network from cafe Zhu is Louis
implementing / using so we're using a
faster our CNN there's a PI faster our
CNN implementation I don't know that
it's in cafe zoo but it's a it's
available on github ok great
so I have another question here from Ann
to detect ripe berries is there any deep
learning involved to get precise color
of the fruit to pick is there any plan
to put the robot arm on wheels so cannot
tell me move row to row inspecting on
fruit to pick so in terms of the
autonomous driving so our machine will
bolt to a tractor and that's really
important because we don't want to solve
the navigation challenges like
navigation and propulsion is kind of
hard and there
the farmers are already really good at
taking these big heavy machines and
moving them all over their fields issue
we think that the the right path long
term towards autonomous navigation of
our system is probably to make the
tractors themselves autonomous and we
see that as somebody else's job yeah and
and the first part of question was about
deployment learning curve
yeah so the the input to our neural
network is RGB image so it does take the
the color and then it just figures out
what to do with that great via some
neural network magic that nobody
understands so I have a bunch of
questions here okay from Matthew
Zimmerman Matthew Zimmer excuse me so
we'll go through them one at a time so
that way you're not bombarded remember
all so get my notebook out good
what's the first step one should take to
get enough investment capital to stay
afloat for a couple of years to build a
full-scale prototype that's a good
question so I think that the typical
like precede investment is going to be
somewhere between 250 and 750 thousand
and so if you have two people that might
last you you know one to two years night
in Silicon Valley of course Slocum
Valley yeah if you're outside Silicon
Valley cost of living is lower I think
it's also harder to get investment
there's also less like
ecosystem support for startups in terms
of the the first step to getting that
investment I talk a lot about making
sure you have proof of customer interest
right when you actually start the
fundraising process making sure you have
a good pitch deck and a business plan is
important like a business plan is like a
15 to 25 page document and writing it
seems awful and stupid you're like why
am I wasting your time my time with us
but actually forces you to write down
like every step of the process write
down all the details of your business
model who you're going to hire when and
how fast you're going to grow and it's
it forces you to add a degree of rigor
to your pitch and your startup that
didn't exist before me I thought was
hard but it was really useful good to
know so the next question is should I
file patents first and then work on
pitching the idea to investors so
patents are super expensive it costs
like 10
$20,000 to file patent the best answer I
don't really know the exact answer the
right answer this question the best
advice I've heard is that you have to
think about what's most likely to kill
the company so in terms of so you sit in
your room and you have this idea you
look at what happens between men and
like having this big company with a
product out in the market there's a
whole bunch of ways where you can fail
just look at what are the most likely
ones like maybe you can't make the right
hires maybe your customers aren't
interested technology doesn't work can't
raise money there's a whole bunch of
things sure
and someone implementing someone like
stealing your technology and employing
the same thing in my opinion is very low
on the list so so a patent is about like
defending yourself from direct
competitors so you probably shouldn't be
focusing on that you should probably be
focusing on making your business better
and file patents later great so for
robotics projects our software
simulations sufficient for pitching and
new to market product and again
obviously this is your opinion yeah I
doubt it I think you need if it's it
like a robotic start start up this going
to have hardware I think you probably
need some hardware so what do you don't
like having a hardware is a lot better
yeah definitely right it makes it easier
to kind of show something that's
physical that people can actually
interact with yeah I think especially in
the demo you want to make it so so
people need some people look your demo
needs some amount of imagination to like
see how it's going to actually work in
the final product you want to make it so
that they need as little imagination as
possible so they they look your thing is
really obvious how they can how it works
a fastener they can like hold in their
hands or grab it makes it a lot easier
so what are some of the greatest risks
you take as a robotic started in terms
of a robotic startup compared to other
startups I think funding is harder
getting funding is harder and hardware
is more expensive like the most recent
arm that we bought was like on the order
of $30,000 so you need more capital
there and also like like physical things
break it's really weird like like
software normally doesn't just ran
break but like you can have like a like
a wire that just snaps and then like
something doesn't work like a camera
that just breaks right so used to be
prepared for that it usually happens
during demos too which is always the
most exciting thing in the world right
almost worst time everything works until
the day of yeah so this next question
here is from Rp he says your gripper has
no cutting tool for the stem there are a
lot of very similar harvesting problems
berries tomorrow's and agriculture which
do you which require a cutter in my
experience some strawberries do too have
you approached Rd on the picking process
so in terms of cutting the stem so when
you buy strawberries in the store they
basically never have stubs in the US I
think in your update all times do so one
of our big goals is to make it so that
growers can deploy this machine in the
mill of the season and just start using
it with with zero barriers to entry and
their whole supply chain is built around
the assumption that there will be no
stems and so if you start producing
strawberries with stems I need to go
change your supply chain and it's
probably not like a impossible thing for
them to do but like then there's this
big like varied entry so we want to make
sure that our strawberries don't have
stems from day once we make so when when
you grasp the berry we pull it off the
plant the stem naturally breaks off
there's no stuff gotcha yeah so next
question is you appear to be using the
real time point cloud for identification
and positioning it looks like you're
doing a fair bit of cropping to optimize
the processing workload can you go into
any detail on the specifics of your
optimized CV workflow beyond the
standard Frodo Graeme photogrammetry
yeah so the the first version of the
software I bill converted the entire
image into a point cloud and I was like
I don't know like millions of points and
they're super slow and so that was a
problem so what the current version does
is it takes the entire so we're using
Kinect cameras the most recent Kinect
camera and it produces a RGB d image so
we take the entire RGB image and we give
that the null Network and it draws a
little bounding box around the
strawberry and then we expand that
bounding box a little bit and for the
rest of process we only ever look at
that part of the image so we convert
that part of the image into a point
cloud and now rather than having
millions of points we have like like
hundreds or
sure been on the rest of the
computations really fast great so next
one is how do you see the future of
agriculture in countries like India
that's a good question I don't know that
much about agriculture in those
countries I think a lot of the challenge
there is around like there's agriculture
in the u.s. is relatively efficient we
can grow really large scales through
machinery through the crop genetics and
and through really detailed
understanding of the of plant health so
you know exactly when you apply water
and when you apply fertilizer and
pesticides and so you can apply all that
in the most limited manner possible
so I think probably taking a lot of
those efficiency things and moving them
to India is most likely the answer I
would imagine that Labor's lost with
challenge there than it is here right so
this next question is looks from like
Elvis in order to be effective at
harvesting are there any specific
requirements for sowing the seeds and/or
the farming surface also will the will
the product just for harvesting or will
it be used for other capabilities too so
our goals makes the farmer doesn't have
to change anything at all
so same seeds same planning process
saying you know bed shapes and
everything so no changes in the growing
process and it was a second part the
question sure will they excuse me will
the product just will the product just
for harvesting or will it have the
capability to so to just harvest okay
yeah harvest is a terms of the labor
cost harvest is a much bigger problem so
the big thing it looks like is it's a
nice drop-in replacement for the current
infrastructure no modifications which
saves farmers and lots of money yeah by
not having to basically restructure
their entire farming process yeah and
and it's actually less about saving them
money and more about increasing the
revenue so we want to take the 20% of
strawberries that are being left to rot
in the fields because I can't
enough people to pick them and make it
so that we can get those off the field
and the clamshells and so they can sell
them and then make it so that they can
increase the size of their farm because
they're not no longer as constrained by
their labor supply and so so if we do
that if we can find a way to make their
business more efficient and increase
their revenue then we don't need to we
don't need to charge a lot less we can
like you know charge the same as what
they're paying now which means good
revenue for us and it means their
businesses go well okay I think that in
general if your startup it's best to try
not to compete on price and try to
compete on quality instead that's a good
point
that's a good methodology to live by
angry next question is is its traffic
hiring we are yeah why looking for good
hardware and software engineers great so
we have we have a huge community of over
1200 people okay if you like you can
send me that job posting that be happy
to spread that with our community we
have a lot of professional and aspiring
roboticists so I'm sure a lot of people
here would be interested okay yeah I'll
send something by and people can also
email me if they want my mail address is
Louis that's Ellie Wis okay at trapped
accom tra p t IC perfect and are you
currently looking to raise another round
of funding or are you yes we're going to
raise another round of funding starting
next month
perfect yeah cool well I think that's
all that's all the questions that we
have for right now okay so thank you
everyone for joining the robotics Q&A
today if you want to learn more about
robotics please visit udacity.com
and also don't forget to check out our
slack community at robotics udacity.com
Liz thank you very much for being here
today appreciate your time thank you
very tiny ting it's been a lot of fun
yeah if anybody has any questions feel
free to send me an email perfect great
thank you thank you
you